So as you may know
*cough*
I'm not working with Disney anymore. It's had great consequences for my career
Where I'm heading in life, what choices do I make?
What people can I trust? A lot of questions have a rose from this
But there's one good thing out of all this just one one thing
one thing
That I can honestly say has been a positive change now. I can finally play my favorite game!!!
Frozen Anna give birth a baby
I'd be wanting to play this game for the longest time
But I've never been able to do it cuz Disney doesn't want it. Love the music love everything. Let's play
Hey hey hey hey, oh
Oh boy, I had to private my other frozen videos
been hidden, it's been hidden since
2015!!!
Fetus, foetus. Oh, sorry foetus
ECG monitor, okay...
Ahh... Doesn't no it doesn't go there uhhh
[Slow clapping] XD
Ok here. We go there. We go. I got something. We did it ok now. We gotta give her the drugs just relax
you're gonna fall asleep and
Never wake up again. Now we add a little bit of magic
A little bit of magic there you go spring a little bit of magic on that belly and then we're gonna cut that shit open
[Laughing loudly]
Sorry, sorry, I got left a little bit of my magic
There you go and a baby. Hey
Circumcised no wait... Schaefer sleep. What did you call in English caesarean section
I was caesarean section-ed so
This this baby could be me, it's like they're surprised that a baby came out. Give birth! A baby. I was a baby
Hey, there's a baby
Let's kill it with a knife apparently oh, we got to cut the
the cord and put it away
and a little better more of that magic
Magic
Wake up
[Beep]
[Beeeeeeep]
[Gary Jules's Mad world plays]
Good game. Good game ah
Jesus Christ can we put it back in urgh what else do we got to do to the stupid baby
We got to wrap it. Okay. Fine. You're a bru burrito now, and then we eat. It that was it
Definitely worth the wait. Oh how I've waited. There's a better game. Don't worry. There's a much better one
There's a much much much better one
Spank Elsa butt
How is this a kids game? This is on a kids game website. Spank Elsa butt look how ready she looks
Spank me senpai!!! Oh my God. I get to pick what I spanked her with wow
gameplay better than mashed effect andromeda a belt *wheezing*
A flip-flop, a ruler what kind of fucking all right. I'll start with the hand see how that works
What just happened? What just happened?
She's crying. You spanked the booty
You spank the booty at 47 miles per hour alright. So what are your qualifications to do this job, Mr.. Shellburn well, you know I?
slap the name of frozen Elsa an average of seven hundred seven miles per hour
Yeah, I'll be running this company now. Thank you very much. Love this sound she makes as well very good sound
The sheer terror for about half a second then just mid cut off here we go. Oh
OHHHHHH!!!
my God
1221... what is that in in kilometers bcos I don't really know.. Wait that's
2,000 kilometers per
Per hour. I see she was fucking it will go through her that will go through her. I always wanted to try spoon
How about we do?
She screams the same way even at 2 miles per hour. What is the slowest spank we can give her?
Don't know why I asked. I don't know why I asked...
What strikes me is that how bizarre these games are for being kids games
They're so strange
but obviously there's a market for them, but
I don't get it. I don't get it... Mata.com the best free girl games online, Jesus Christ
Just like Jesus Christ
What is the best ones Mata.com the best free girl games online?
Alright you said that
It's almost like the simpsons you know they've done literally everything like frozen two Elsa dolphin. How???
How does that make any sense? Oh my God there's literally breastfeeding. What the fuck. Oh my God
Is that the baby???
Here's the phone
Amazing
Here's a blanket, okay. Have some water
Oh my god have a bell
EUGHHHHHH
Have an oxygen mask always ready, you know
Always always ready
Oh, I got a manage all the stats
Shit. She's running out of water. She's running out of water
She running out of water. This is it like snap?
But actually terrifying because the consequences are real give her the bell
GIVE HER THE BELL
Why she dating jack frost I thought she was dating someone else ah
AAAAAHHHHHHHHHH
When is the ambulance coming? We're having a baby. We're having a baby. God damn it
Oh thank God. Go to the hospital.
Oh my god my god
I-I-I don't think
Oh my God the baby's out. The baby's out the baby's out everyone
Oh, it's all disgusting uhhh take a sponge
Take a sponge. It's way better than a baby trust me.
You don't want to you don't want a baby you want a sponge
fuck no, I can you make it shhh
You know what? I finally is actually to be quite educational
Bye bye, baby!!!
Hahahaha have some drugs
You'll you'll feel better have another one, and it's methylenedioxyphenethylamine (ecstasy) kinda, and we can only make the baby be quiet
My God. Oh my God breastfeeding is normal breastfeeding is normal, and you should be able to do it in public
It's a kids game everyone. It's a kids game. I know how to play a kids game. Okay. I'm smart enough
I don't know anymore. I just don't know anymore. I'm starting to reconsider. You know oh my God. What's wrong for their eyes
What's wrong with her eyes are they like that in the whole game?
What's wrong with her eyes?
NOO!!!
Okay, oh my God. She's so scary. I hate her. What is wrong with heeerrrrr
What is wrong with her eyes?
What happened? What is the game about?
Keemstar was here
Apparently
I think she took drugs
She made a mess and we have to clean it up for her and she's looking at me and I'm scared
I'm scared of what she will do to me. She peed on the fucking ground. She peed where do I broom?
There we go
Ok I got it I got it. I know how to play a kids game. Okay? I'm smart enough
We got to glue this now. We'll just throw it away
The table was like that. We got to fix the table we get all right. Hey. Hey you gotta play
Yeah, it's very detailed this game
You know if ya put as much detail in as the the eyes that would have been great if they did that but she wrecked
The place like what what did she do she spat at the mirror? Why would she do that???
Good job
Thank you text
If only I could get the validation from from Anna then then it would mean something
Nice don't patronize me
Okay, I know you don't mean it
Thank you. My castle is clean out. She thought it. She didn't say it
She just thought it
You're welcome. Can I go now???
PLEASEEEE???
How can kids play this and not be traumatized
OH AND THE EYES AGAIN!!!
The eyes the fucking eyes my God everything I got everything
What did you do? Anna, what did you do? And I were you looking so happy
Thaa thaa YEA take that shit art
Wash that shit up
Snow glows white on the mountain tonight
Not a footprint to be seen
A kingdom of isolation
And it looks like I'm queen
The wind is howling like this swirling storm inside
We're gonna spark you up with a spark you up
We are definitely concealing
OOOHHHHH
I'm gonna end it here because I think I'll go insane if I keep playing
And I think I'm worried about you as you as well, but yeah, I hope you enjoyed this that adventure with me
I hope you had fun
Leave a like if you enjoyed all this appreciate all the support that I get..
and I'll see you bros, in another one.. Brofist :)